well vaccinations and mask use continue
to be a hot topic throughout the
pandemic and now we're facing
ever-changing guidelines we want to get
your questions answered by a medical
professional to eliminate any false
information that may be causing you some
confusion christian costar is joining us
live in studio with some of those
answers well brian and denise today i
spoke to dr jeff morasky with hca health
care we went over a couple of your
questions about vaccinations which masks
work the best and of course protecting
kids unable to get their shot
it's not 100 percent but it's really
good at keeping you from getting
hospitalized dr jeff marowski with hca
health care says vaccinations and
boosters are the best protection against
covet 19 as more people return to normal
activities so going out to those events
and being exposed is a relatively lower
risk choice
that means you don't have underlying
medical conditions or you're not going
to be around people who have underlying
medical conditions children five years
and younger are not yet eligible for the
vaccine but dr moroski says there are
things parents can do to help minimize
the risk helping them wash their hands
stay clean trying to reduce the
exposures where possible if they can
wear a mask that's a great thing to do i
know how hard it is with small children
home testing kits have become hard to
come by across the country we asked our
medical expert about the difference
between these over-the-counter kits to
getting tested by a professional the
accuracy of those tests really depend on
how well you do it and when you take it
and they're both really reliable
well dr moroski added that n95 masks
offer the best protection but we all
know they can be a bit uncomfortable
overall he says a mask is always better
than no mask christian cassette is live
local now